yoth vente sarkozy obtient s'auto sur
turbo desmond micro tu tombes pas déjà
un pl ace est parti et pas mal de
nouveautés les plats d'un fois qu'on a
fait une vidéo sur ce jeu moi je suis là
et c'est charmant voilà je vous ai fait
une petite surprise
s'il vous plaît elle a vraiment aucun
style fait taaone des nouveaux véhicules
ces partis boss rhône voilà ah oui ça un
petit échec
c'est le début de cette vue est arrêté
un échec total vas-y tu as beau mon gars
baseggio mots choisis via revient via le
banc écoutez je me retrouve change de
maps déjà à hockey hockey atome est
également attaqué par soumis ne sais pas
si tu as déjà de faire des loopings
latéraux à eux deux quand je songe on y
arrive mais on va tenter
j'ai beau me regardent comme ça je suis
pour rien vraiment je t'assure je suis
pour rien c'est pas de ma faute
il va passer en plus le con il le fait
pas trop a eu c'est qu'on peut se fait
ailleurs au plus tard à tuer me vaut
cyrus c'est parti non il va tomber mais
de quoi il est carrément tomber non
seulement il est bien il est bien
accroché à sa [ __ ] chain
oui au nom de mes achats vrais gens puis
surtout je me dis qu'il ça pourra pas
être pire et si c'est pire hf web
base-jump on est tous avec toi gogh à
vue qu'est-ce qui se passe non non non
il faut plus de stabilité la voilà comme
ça nickel ok host et chaud oui mon gars
restent accrochés reste accroché
lambeaux fait comme si c'était des
croquettes des croquettes jumbo poisse
aux croquettes [ __ ] adore le mec quoi
et après de circulation sur cette map
les repoussons les limites un peu plus
loin ces gens voilà parfait parfait mon
job de hockey au à judy djobo joe beauté
ou djomo j'aime tout
je la trouvais ils étaient juste là à
possède la gueule je propose la recette
jones keith on l'appelle dans le milieu
voilà comme ça au petit mec le premier
kouame de hockey à je te sentais pas ok
voilà je ne cache pas ma déception au
kehrweg si je réussis ou pas cette fois
mon gars que tu vas faire bitches
question s était pas
c'est ce qui s'est passé entre les deux
puces et tout une vraie chorégraphie ça
passe quoi y'a carreau une exposante
pourquoi ça fait une explosion pareil
parce qu'il a touché le ventricule
gauche du moteur si je connais beaucoup
en mécanique stocks le ventricule ce
futur moteur tu sais la conduire sa
voiture ou pas j'ai ma réponse
c'est passé le premier s'est passé
deuxième s'est pas fait troisième c'est
ça qu'on veut jumbo tu m'entends sous le
ciment tu m'entends opara maintenant on
peut changer de corps djombo c'est
plutôt ça c'est vrai nos rues
dangereuses pas pour john bost et sa
porsche pas pour john bost et sa harley
d'aller voir me croyais pas et de deux
tranquillement en fait ne faisait rien
vu merci et 2,3 tranquillement voilà
trois morts je veux dire je crois je
fait poursuivre par des policiers
normalement qu'allez vous faire contre
moi et mon caddie donc ça va faire mal
je fais le malin mais choc on apprend
très très cher ils vont se mettre à me
suivre c'est ça non non vas-y mais j'ai
même pas vous laissiez [ __ ] mais pour
vous un peu de ça what you're gonna do
what you're gonna tonnes le touriste
quoi lemay qui conduit mais qui est un
peu celui touriste semi conducteurs de
bus voie lactée vous allez faire mon
gars vite le truc pour accélérer vite
dit c'est bon là à bientôt
ça c'est un appel de phares à un peu
brutale ça aussi c'est un appel de
phares mais un peu brutal arrivé en
scooter
voilà parce que il est débridée
finalement et qu'on l'a pas volé bon on
l'a volée ok on a beau les scouts et on
peut le dire djabou est un délinquant ça
doit regarder c'est la tête du mec qui
est drôle un truc c'est un homme quand
même attention attention non où est ma
tête ma tête mais qui signale vu quoi la
caméra espion un kiff quoiqu'un tu à
vomir jeunes joueurs alors je veux
battre au principe de cette map qu'est
ce qu'il soit frais sur une brouille qui
ajuste un boost et il ya probablement la
route la plus in her du monde c'est à
dire que même si je suis un petit chien
en vélo je vais mourir comme ça
non regardez leskiw oui regardez jumbo
malins aux mines madness je me doute que
madeira commence à ramsey indique un peu
le nombre de mines que mes gars du
maître
il s'est fait trop plaisir il s'est fait
trop plaisir le conte savamment pc tu
tiens déjà moi je suis un pompier ok
donc je ne crains pas les mines je ne
crains pas le feu normalement risque
rien regardé en haut et on y voit
secteur ayant des impacts non mais c'est
inévitable - je rage quit voilà je vais
à au travail au bureau office regardez
moi ça c'est à dire qu'on a un chemin
pour tomber et un chemin pour tomber
aussi merci beaucoup aux hommes qui
avaient ce niveau très aimable alors est
ce qu a volé on a un oiseau mais qu il
vole vraiment voilà la rejoint
l'autoroute puis on prend la 86e sont
marseille voilà quoi mais j'aime bien
sûr pourquoi j'attache j'ai mis un mur
pourquoi nommer mais quoi hobbies la map
est buggé ça démarre tout seul
voilà un garage t'es sauvé la vie tu me
dis merci tout de suite tu ne dis pas
merci tu es sûr je vais pas m'en vouloir
je vais même rien faire ryder caché à
l'arrière du véhicule en position foetus
je ne suis pas rancunier mais j'aime et
je t'ai sommet en voulant buts et père
jon voight tu vois tu je tu retournes
affronté les policiers tout content ça
allait déjà beau en plus c'est bien la
pose provocante quoi pour passer devant
les policiers
oui bien sûr y'a pas de problème mon
véhicule fait 28 ans qu'est ce qui vous
arrive
j'me tire à bientôt on tentera une
petite figure devant eux
on sait tous ses as pas marché mais on a
tous envie d'essayer un rôle à bien
provocante appose arrête de faire le ch
a battu [ __ ] fait une pause provoquant
vraiment attention la petite figure la
petite figure avec le policier derrière
n'ont pas assez de mails c'est quoi vous
avez besoin d'araignée incroyable
regarder au oui on est libre on y va
comme ça direct alors les policiers
soyez padeg je vais je suis sain
d'esprit et bien dans mon corps aïe
non oui on fait du yoga sommes
maintenant policiers
c'est pas grave bien faire du yoga avec
moi vient bien être sain d'esprit
je suis bien là je suis bien sûr toi mon
gars à toi t'es pas bien aimé ça de la
position tu l'a mal tenu aussi j'ai vu
on va appeler cette position je cherche
la gamelle c'est pas avec un jeu de mot
avec le fait que son achat il ya même de
croquettes n'auront peut-être pas oui
non c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon sens
et on entend ça se passera comme prévu
ça se passe pas du tout comme prévu ça
commence très mal
la tonne en fait il se cache dans ce
scrutin est super malin regarder en
passant devant les policiers au pis
cache derrière et aux obus [ __ ] à
jamais ah oui c'est beau ça on dirait
ninja what you're gonna do when i'm
cambon attention voiture bah ouais non
qu'est ce tu vas faire mon gars je peux
28 tonnes ok figure et rich continue
sans moi mais son me faisais mes façons
personne même dans le jeu
oui là annonce à faire une roue va
tomber oh non même pas rhodia qui dans
ce [ __ ] c'était une belle dans sa
moment sans raison la la la la la
[ __ ] de danse qu'elle sait que sur une
moto ok on change de route ne
retrouveront jamais non c'est un flic en
civil bordel nous a eu alors la mecque
toile bus bon gars qu'est ce que vous
allez faire mon gars voilà là ils ont vu
qu'ils ont vu mon joli twelve sont tous
attirés par mois par ce corps divin de
chats finalement lâché moi non je vous
donne pas mon toit souple et c'est le
montois n'a plus rien dans ce plus je
véhicule appelez maximus à vous vous
êtes tout ce qu'on vous a même pu rouler
non maximus comment tu as pu faire ça
plus tard bâle et à l'eau il s'en fout
il m'a abandonnée au milieu des
policiers quoi la rogers avec la
position canards ont fait un cas n'a pas
regardé
je suis même du coup de bassin pour ta
tiré vers moi oh on a fait un petit
créneau attention bus à versailles pour
que mon jeu là mais n'ont jamais parce
que on s'envole bon gars ok voilà je
suis parti aux pieds bon on m'avait eu
des constructions site the bright eyes
accord de maman ce génial
allons-y soldats avec mon big beauty y
est on est sûr c'est casser les choses
on n'a rien cassé on va par nos jours
n'a rien cassé et pof in the wall au
c'est beau me suces bihorel à efes rouge
elle s'est pris un gros coup sur les
fesses
c'est là il me semble qu'on l'avait déjà
fait mais elle est incroyable ok comme
ça ça a passé mais ok en place le
premier on passera pas deuxième on a
réussi on avance on va laisser on va
laisser aller retour n'est laid mais ça
aller retour dont je suis ses copines
les voyageurs souhaitant prendre cette
vidéo sur turbo dit spruce j'espère que
ça vous a plu c'est le cas n'hésitez pas
à aller mais comme d'habitude est
d'avoir gardé comme d'habitude on se
retourne la vie dans une nouvelle vidéo
et je veux me donner un style vous en
vidéo mais s'est tenu bon tiens tout le
monde est bien pis
[Musique]
non